there is a monument in these ruins that
stands above the forest
follow the trail you will see it through
the canopy
it was in these ruins i found august
after skurlock found out
gang had fighters stationed here hoping
he'd catch more
right
natives
so
right
so
keem
depending on
your alien friend august if this is
where you found him
maybe he'll turn up around here again so
if he can turn invisible
may not be so easy to spot him if august
wants to be found
august will find us it took a long time
for august to trust me
but after what skurlock did i could not
say what august might be thinking
anymore
that name august where does it come from
anyway
it is closest to how the name sounds in
august's native tongue
something like
keep my back covered
what do you know about these ruins
thiago i believe they were built by
august's ancestors
they've been abandoned for a long time i
do not know what happened to them
do you know what happened to august's
people are there more of them
i have last august many times either my
questions are not
understood or august is avoiding them
there's the monument up ahead i need to
get the receiver up there
outrider these ruins are incredible i
wish i had the time to study them
perhaps when we come back this way well
if we come back
um
tahiti i got a direction
[Music]
but there's a big storm warn the others
we need to find shelter
in there
august you came back
[Music]
what exactly is your friend doing
bailey [ __ ] look at this [ __ ] thing
it's making the [ __ ] storm
no wait it's not what you think august
can channel it
control it look august is helping us
no [ __ ] bailey you need to stand down
no i don't think so think maybe i've
gone far enough on your little death
march
think i'm going back to corrigan and
taking this freak with me
come here
so this is what it feels like bailey be
careful
you don't know what this energy could do
to you
oh no go
go
really you don't want to do this
you could not be more wrong
freak
oh
bailey you need to listen to me
[ __ ] you think just because you have
all that power you can boss me around
well not anymore i'm taking you down
you can't kill me
you think just because you have all that
power you can boss me around
well not anymore i'm taking you down
no you don't win this
why is it going away no no wait
wait no
she's breathing but her spinal cord's
most likely severed if she survives
she'll never walk again good chicken
watch the monsters eat her liver
let's go no reason to leave her to
suffer
no
i i don't care what she's done we need
to bring her
i will take care of her personally i
i would do the same for any of you
really
okay now the no [ __ ] version
my vision of the meadow
i've been seeing more of it bailey's in
it
how's it supposed to come true if she's
not with us
in your vision is everyone there
how i don't know
have you told him
he doesn't listen
to anything i say
hey yaku we need to talk
there's i don't know how to say this
this could turn ugly for some of us
whatever you're rambling about forget is
i need to get the truck ready
yeah but just listen what would die here
there what's the difference hell we
should both be dead a hundred times
over every minute we are still breathing
is already a bonus
so shut up about it yeah
hold up movement in the trees behind us
that's king
probably wants his revenge ah he can get
in line